[Music]
america lighthouses are symbols of the
coastal communities they've served for
centuries so what happens when they're
no longer needed and left to fall apart
that's what happened in a small village
of about 6 000 people in the florida
keys some people in islamorada are
rallying behind a crumbling lighthouse
they say it's worth saving manuel
baharkis traveled to the keys to meet
the people throwing a lifeline to an
aging icon
four miles off the coast of islamorada
rising 136 feet above the aqua sea
stands alligator reef lighthouse a
fixture on the horizon here for more
than a century
it's a beloved symbol of this community
on the village seal postcards t-shirts
souvenirs even hanging over your head at
the local diner replicas both small and
big this is a 14 foot
replica of alligator lighthouse that i
built
local artist larry hurlf is perhaps its
biggest fan
his sculptures around town made in honor
of the offshore icon you know growing up
here all my life i kind of always took
it for granted
until one day about a decade ago when a
boat ride to the lighthouse changed
everything for really the first time in
my life i truly in depthly
looked at this thing everything was
rusted through and that's the first time
i realized you know what you know
condition
the lighthouse was in the thought of
losing it was you know quite
you know scary at that point because
what it means to us built just after the
civil war it had shined its light since
1873
guiding countless ships and lives away
from danger but for larry its meaning
goes deeper my mother and my brother
their ashes are sprinkled there you
decided that's where your mother and
brother would would rest yes and that's
where i will saving alligator light
became larry hurt's mission but it was
in the government's hands and out of
frustration i just thought one day
i'm going to swim to alligator
lighthouse and see if that can drum up
some type of
attention attention
it certainly did eight miles round trip
the publicity stunt in 2012 made
headlines and caught the attention of
rob dixon who ran a charity at the local
pool it's imran's statue of liberty you
know to put it bluntly it would be a
totally different
community if that were not there
the next year they organized an even
bigger swim around the lighthouse hoping
the u.s government would notice and make
some repairs
but still in 2014 the light went out
despite their efforts modern advances in
navigation like gps had made the
lighthouse obsolete there would be no
repairs in fact the coast guard
determined it no longer needed an active
lighthouse there at all it was just a
sad moment for everyone in town to
you know everyone said the lights out
the lights out
because we've seen it all our life there
was one glimmer of hope a federal law
called the national historic lighthouse
preservation act it is strictly for the
coast guard to dispose of their lights
that they no longer have a need for but
they still see is integral to the
history of the united states ellen
rankin a historian with the national
park service helps manage the program
she explained the government could
transfer ownership of the lighthouse but
there's a catch not going to give this
away to somebody who's going to put a
sports bar in there correct you want
this to be someone who's going to take
care of it for the greater public good
correct that's exactly the purpose of
this program i said maybe we should try
to get it so for months they worked on
their application making their case to
be the new keepers of the lighthouse
there was no guarantee that you were
going to get it no it
and it seemed like a real long shot at
the beginning and as we got closer to
submitting this application it started
to
seem like a real thing that could happen
so like
well who's better than us nobody we're
the home team the u.s government agreed
in december the deed for alligator
lighthouse was officially signed over to
its new owners to me that is the
greatest honor
yeah so this is the next chapter in its
history this is it it will be a
monumental task stabilizing and
restoring it could take years and
millions of dollars i've never done this
before but somebody had to do it i said
somebody has to take this ball and run
with it and get it over the goal line
and with larry's enthusiasm and our
community i know it's going to be
amazing he's got a chance to work on a
real live lighthouse you've gone from
the sculptures to the real thing
yeah i think the sculptures are on back
burner now a little easier the
sculptures than this guy
yeah but absolutely not as satisfying as
this will be its lantern may have been
extinguished but alligator light's
future is looking brighter already for
cbs morning's manuel bajorquez island
mirada florida
i love this because lighthouses are
symbols of direction purpose and of
course
spreading light to those in the dark
yeah and larry's family is buried there
his enthusiasm is what made this happen
yep that's right the white house is very
sentimental for a lot of people that's
right nicely done nicely done guys